[MUSIC]
How do you dream about changing the world?
Maybe it's by starting a company
that helps women look and
feel their best,
creating hundreds of jobs and internships.
Maybe you're successful in manufacturing
first, before you turn to philanthropy,
changing children's lives forever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or
maybe it's by getting
elected to the West Wing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Tonight,
I'd like to suggest a different,
but just as rewarding option.
Serving in your local government.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Sometimes,
it feels hard to separate
government from a TV comedy.
And when you can't take
government seriously,
it's hard to care about it or value it.
Early feedback for this talk included,
could you find a different word for
government?
>> [LAUGH]
>> It turns people off when you
say it so much.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I haven't found any good synonyms for
government yet.
But tonight, I want to make the case
that you should take it seriously,
and consider getting involved with
your city hall or state capitol.
Because state and local government
is the most impactful organization
that you've never cared about.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And all of you smart, talented people
should care about an organization
that moves billions of dollars and
affects millions of
lives in our community.
Right now participation in local
government is low across the board.
Only 19% of Americans have contacted
a local official in the last year.
Only 24% have attended
a local public meeting.
Those rates are even lower
amongst young Americans.
But when I asked my friends here if
they'd consider getting involved,
I hear things like, it's not the highest
and best use of their time, or
that government is slow and efficient.
There's this perception that your
frustrating experience at the DMV
would translate into the impact that
you could have by getting involved.
And I can't promise you that
government offers the autonomy that you
might have at a starter, or it will
be as first moving as a tech company.
But I also don't think any of us would
like it if our local police force are fire
appointments started using Move fast and
break things as their motto.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Slowness in government is
a design feature, it prevents any
one of us from consolidating power,
and allows all of us to have
a say in how we are governed.
And I can promise you, that the slowness
that you sometimes see in government
does not translate into the impact that
you could have by getting involved.
There are three reasons why,
influence, scale, and talent.
Let's talk about influence.
Take Cameron Johnson,
who graduated from the JSB in 2008,
these days Cameron is the director
of product innovation at Netflix.
He's also the Vice Mayor
of San Carlos California.
During the day, Cameron works
on video streaming when you turn
your phone from portrait
to landscape mode.
At night he goes to Transportation Board
meetings where he decides on policies for
roads, public transit and
autonomous vehicles for
the 7 million people who
live in the South Bay.
Cameron works on your user experience,
on the Netflix app, and on the 101.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I've seen this ability to have
immediate influence first hand.
When I was 25 years old, I worked with
the mayor of Salt Lake County on a project
to help the homeless and
men leaving the county jail.
At 25, I got to chair committees,
coordinate data sharing agreements,
and launched an $11 million project
that provided job training,
rehabilitation services and
housing for over 300 men.
So, what's the multiplier
effect of that influence?
Let's talk about scale.
You could, for example,
go work at the Gates Foundation,
which just gave $1.7 billion to education,
that's scale, right.
The man himself, Bill Gates, actually said
it best in his foundation's annual letter.
While our foundation is
the largest in the world,
the amount we give is small
compared to government.
The Gates Foundation total
endowment of $44 billion,
is less than the $76 billion
that the State of California
spends on its public
school system in one year.
And it's not just education, if you care
about healthcare, energy, transportation,
chances are that the government deploys
far more resources than philanthropy does.
Lastly, I want to talk about talent.
There's a term in baseball called,
value over replacement player.
It argues that a batters value isn't
the absolute number of runs he hits,
but the runs he hits over the average
player who would've replaced him.
Think about your own
value over a replacement.
For example, if you're going into
consulting you'll be joining
the 985 other GSB graduates since 2003.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
what happens when you leave
being in BCG in a few years?
They'll likely replace you with
someone 95% as good from HPS.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The same is not true of government.
Since 2003, only 22 of us or half of 1%
have gone directly in the government.
Out of over 33,000 alums
in the alumni directory,
only 88 are involved in state and
local government.
That means that our cities and states
just don't have that many people who
think about traffic and
congestion with an operations perspective.
Or run a local public health campaign
with a marketing background.
Or even hire key personnel with
recommendations from Joel Peterson.
Your value over replacement could be high.
As you leave the GSB, you're looking for
ways to have impact quickly.
It's why people do search funds, to run an
organization a few years after graduating.
It's why do people consulting,
to influence large powerful organizations.
It's why people do private acuity to
deploy large pools of capital to improve
organizations.
You can do all three of these things
a mile down the road at City Hall.
I've spent this whole talk talking
about what you could do for government.
But in the end, I'd ask that you value
government for what it does for you.
Local government takes out your trash,
it repairs the roads that you drive on and
pays the policeman who pulls you over for
speeding.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It likely runs the schools that
you attended as a child and the schools
that your children will attend.
It decides whether you
have a composting bin, or
whether to utilize renewable energy for
millions of residents.
It runs hospitals, provides healthcare,
and cares for the elderly.
These essential services aren't
just things that happen to exist
in our communities.
They were developed and
they can be improved by you and by me.
Teddy Roosevelt once said, far and away
the best prize that life has to offer,
is the chance to work
hard at work worth doing.
You all have a lot of options
in how you change the world.
But I hope that you consider
public service, it is hard work,
but it is work worth doing.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]